but how my lands
like more than 15 years we see what
even one of the surgeons
can't get used to see
how my lands when we know that
these crimes against humanity are
planned with motive economic basma
[Music]
rare are  the days when the news in
my region does not reveal a new
human tragedy last week more than 50
people were massacred with machetes
in the territory of beni in north kivu
pregnant women are disemboweled
and babies meet the bodies of  women
has become a real
battlefield and rape is used as
a weapon of war
already a single case of rape is serious and
requires inaction from all of us in my
country there are hundreds of thousands of
women raped each woman raped I
identify
to my wife
each raped mother each
raped mother I identify her with
my mother and each raped child gelid
years here to my children
in a world of inversion of values
where violence is banal  read taking
forms and still abominable refuse
violence these dissident beings
by drawing the world's attention to the
need to protect women in
times of armed conflict you have
refused indifference in the face of one of the
greatest humanitarian disasters of
modern times there will be no peace
or economic and social development
without respect for human rights
today everything is before the
whole world of europe expresses its
solidarity
with us it wants to walk with us in our
quest for restoration  of a
dignified Congolese life
our country is sick but together with
our friends from parliaments we can and
we will treat them thank you
[Applause]
[Music]